e a quality content
ecco mi posso non fare il tutorial che
mi sembra ciao amore tutorial penn che
non puoi fare altro se non i tutorial
saltare almeno la parte del tutorial
perché mi sembra un gioco intuitivo
o forse no ai wire ge betz prejean and
we need preside mi ha rubato un tool
continuo a posso giocare anche che chi è
questa tizia svariate fissi ammazzare
zinne cosa sto vedendo capisco che i
giochi moderni sono fatti con una fisica
decisamente buona però non mi immaginavo
così buona dato la telecamera è finta
non si girava solo su e giù sinistra
destra non ci va va bene vi piacciono
ragazzi contenuti che porto su youtube
siete entusiasti di tutto questo quanti
soldi ho speso per questa cagata di
gioco ma perché hanno fatto la versione
natalizia del gioco e hanno messo il
cappello di natale non avevo visto ero
talmente concentrato sul por chile di
gioco che è che non avevo neanche notato
che il gatto aveva un cappello di natale
[Musica]
macché accili ha preso sta tizia cosa è
successo a cene sulla schiena da me lo
frate mi serve allora brutta punta se
non mi reco l'affare l'itis quarto in
due con i miei artigli la tigre
hai capito muoviti lamis pesce ho preso
tutto ciò che devi fare è trovare
quattro gatti che sono nascosti nella
palestra va bene 123 a quattro erano
allora ragazzi ora che vi ho trovato
lasciamo le cose serie dopo spacciamo un
po d'erba è innanzitutto gigi gigi va in
porta che io tiro vai vai vai
gigi non sei andato in porta muoviti o
ti vengo a graffiare la famiglia mi stai
cagando ki do picchiare due cazzotti in
faccia gigi ti ho già detto che il capo
qua non te lo devo spiegare di nuovo
nuovi team porta il tuo con la tua
famiglia immortali scossero tutti uno
per uno dovete morire tutte le nove vite
9 18 27 vite andranno spezzate oggi è
inutile che fate michael jackson occhio
a franco lì dietro che poverino la
sorprendete in più lo prendete il
rapporto seguitemi veloci veloci ho
detto cioè riviviamo adulto di rügen
host quando vi rivolgete a me vi dovete
rivolgere dicendo la parola signore
avete capito chiaro bene a exit
beh sono 5 euro ben spesi
great major o un gatto girmi a name il
nome del gatto sfintere bene perché me
lo sfintere ok play with sfintere al
freddo siete di nuovo ubriachi e alle
fredde morirono dentro un cespuglio
c'è un pesce su una tartaruga ma il
gioco fu più accurato di questo salve
signor è tutto a posto
sa che ho pagato questo gioco 5 euro lo
dice lei perché l'ho fatto
cosa sta facendo ma chi acidi le dai a
colazione spiega mi congratulo shaun
gilbert non sono gilbert sono sfintere
quindi vedi di correggere subito sennò
chiedo il rimborso del gioco e te lo
assicuro che cosa non capisco non
capisco se il gioco è serio o meno se
non capisco ce l'hanno fatto apposta per
mongoloidi e cazzo cosa sto vedendo
cos'è sta roba
salve
devo aver assunto acidi senza rendermene
conto è pino lo sto già seguendo io
elevati dalle balle non più contento di
non aver capito meglio così nei 5 euro
che ho speso non era compresa la fisica
quella va comprato a parte un è un dlc
la fisica e la vendono dopo ok a gesù
costo boeing be careful sfintere e stava
andando a guardare le altre case non
posso
giro io commetto un cactus i cdo stack
congratulations sfintere io found al 30
fishes a siamo e nella casa dei vicini
hydra che siamo ciao ti ho reclutato
vieni fratello arriva a fare i boss
andiamo a spacciare nel parchetto viene
ma in questo mondo sono più intelligenti
le piante delle degli esseri umani cioè
inverno fa ci sono meno 20 gradi e
questi girano nudi tra vione ma come fa
c'era in topless che nevica cristo
cambio orca vacca ancora one facciamo
una dark polo gang a regà siamo british
a inseguimenti i polizieschi qua ci sarà
c'entra viene di prima perfetto che ci
fai qua travi un anota e una donna non
avevo capito lo pensavo ci avessi il
pezzo questo e per i gatti sti anonimi e
la riunione
ciao mi chiamo sfintere non faccio palle
di pelo da otto settimane grazie grazie
cosa non è questo gioco con meglio spesi
i miei soldi come gli ospiti a fare il
ri found e rifare quando non sei
soddisfatto di un gioco tv danno i soldi
potrei forse di farlo però mi rendo
conto che i creatori di questo gioco ci
hanno speso delle energie
poche però ce l'hanno spese quindi
magari non lo facciamo
8 grazie erano bravissimo
direi che va bene così anzi a proposito
fammi vedere un hub della comunità fa
vedere cosa ne pensa la gente di play
with gilbert sembra proprio carino è
fantastico thank you raul ma che gente
sisters
ed allora ma sono tutti o
sanno tutti trullando perché non capisco
vabbè allora il gruppo e scriviamo
never play and some thing that ai reali
one to thank you for this master ps va
bene ragazzi io concludo qui l'episodio
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
giocare con i gatti sempre stata una mi
interessa non lo sapete come se vi piace
lo racconta mi piace anche adesso cioè
come intende description stasera si
schieri ci vediamo al prossimo gatto ne
caricato da sabrina registro sta roba in
live tanto ci vuole poco bene ragazzi
[Musica]